The Landmark Summit between South Korea
and Japan comes at a time of increasing
Regional challenges for both Nations
just a couple of hours before Yun sukyol
departed on the first bilateral visit by
a serving South Korean president to
Japan in 12 years North Korea launched a
long-range missile in the same direction
the weapon was confirmed as an
intercontinental ballistic missile of
the kind North Korea has been developing
and showing off at military parades in
the past couple of years video released
by the Japanese Air Force shows what
seems to be a missile coming down after
re-entry into the atmosphere
the launch comes in a week that marks
the start of annual military drills
between South Korean and U.S forces that
will include large-scale field exercises
Washington wants to see closer relations
between its two East Asian allies not
only as a counter to North Korean
threats and the growing military might
of China but also to maintain a
technological Edge in the production of
strategically important semiconductors
we have confirmed the importance of
vigorously promoting security
cooperation between Japan South Korea
and the United States Japan announced
its lifting export curbs on materials
needed for High-Tech manufacturing
imposed during the recent spat with
South Korea president Yoon is trying to
restore ties that have soured
considerably in recent years but in
South Korea it's a highly controversial
move relations have been scarred by
Decades of colonial rule from Tokyo
during the last century which culminated
in atrocities committed by Japanese
troops in World War II weekly protests
are still held against the enforced use
of so-called Comfort women in military
brothels
and Yoon has proposed settling the issue
of Koreans forced to work in Wartime
factories by compensating victims from a
voluntary fund instead of fining the
Japanese companies involved a bold offer
seeming to prove yoon's sincerity in
strengthening ties
going forward we will continue to
actively communicate and cooperate
through shuttle diplomacy meeting as
often as necessary regardless of
formality but opponents back in South
Korea accuse him of a diplomatic climb
down in this deeply troubled
relationship Rod McBride Al Jazeera
Seoul